Let's say you're speaking to a room full of people who want to start their own companies.
You say to them these:
"I've met a lot of startup CEOs,...
...these are the three biggest mistakes that you shouldn't make that I've seen a lot."
What are those three mistakes?
So, it would start with focus and being able to very clearly articulate...
...what it is that the company is ultimately trying to accomplish.
What is the mission of the organization?
And for that mission to be as singular and unique to that company as it can be.
And to focus on fewer things.
And with fewer things, you'll be able to do them better.
It's easier to communicate.
It's easier to internalize.
It's easier to execute upon.
And as companies scale, they end up doing more things.
That's the nature of it.